we're learning more and more about the
concern and panic from Donald Trump
about the multiple Russia investigations
and it's not just unhinged tweets laced
with bizarre typos capitalization
parentheses and quotation marks it's
also related to the revelation from a
New York Times report that during this
past summer Donald Trump tried to get
multiple Republican senators to end the
Senate investigation into possible Trump
Russia collusion we already knew that
Trump asked Comey to lay off of Mike
Flynn and to wrap up the Russia
investigation ASAP we now have a report
in The New York Times corroborated by
six or more lawmakers and aides to those
lawmakers Republican Richard burr is one
example Trump told him I'm eager to see
this investigation end according to the
same New York Times report a Republican
close to a Senate Republican Richard
burr spoke on the condition of anonymity
said Trump was quote very forceful in
trying to get senator Burr to end the
investigation Trump told Mitch McConnell
and Roy Blunt who were also key
Republicans and this thing quickly Trump
complained to mcconnell and bob corker
that republicans in the house weren't
doing enough to make the russia story
disappear another republican said that
trump contacted them not to end the
russia investigation but instead to
start an investigation into Hillary
Clinton and then another element of this
report is that Trump would sometimes
call Republican senators when Trump
senior staff wasn't around which implies
he's kind of like a little kid right he
knew he was doing a bad boy and he
didn't want mommy and daddy to see and
know about it I can just imagine Trump
sneaking away into the bathroom with his
with his phone calling these Senate
Republicans and saying hey can you can
you end this an oh Jared Kushner walks
in what are you doing in there Donald do
you need help wiping no no no I'm fine
I'm on the phone it is like a little kid
and it is not about whether this is or
isn't unconstitutional or is or isn't
obstruction of justice which it all
might be by the way it's about whether
you believe in separation of powers or
you don't the Pres
should not have nor should they try to
exert influence over the Justice
Department over the judicial branch the
president should not be trying to get
investigations into him ended by a
branch that's supposed to be a check or
balance on his power that's what this is
really about I mean it's crazy to me
because I think if big news breaks in
this whole Trump Russia investigation it
probably wouldn't happen in the Senate
or the house investigation it will
happen under Robert Moeller's absolutely
so this is just a waste of your
political capital in a way I believe
that the Senate and House investigations
have in different ways been discredited
or at least they've been deflated by
different things that have happened it's
the Moller investigation that's really
the existential threat to Donald Trump
yes are you running so much risk and
then there's really no reward you can
get out of this now the technicality
that the defenders of Trump will hang
their hats on is that yes Trump is
attempting to influence the
investigations but it's not undue
influence because of course undue
influence is totally subjective
unwarranted or inappropriate because of
it being excessive or disproportionate
whether Trump's influence Wow and I did
something rude I didn't mute my phone
for today's program because I'm so
excited by these stories whether
something is excessive or
disproportionate is sort of in the eye
of the beholder he asked for senators
which I guess is okay but if he had
asked seven senators to end the
investigation than it would have
wouldn't have been allowed now to be
thorough to go back to the obstruction
thing this does seem like obstruction of
justice if you look at us 18 USC 1505
whoever corruptly or by threats or force
or by any threatening letter or
communication influences obstructs or
impedes our endeavors to influence
obstruct or impede the due and proper
administration of the law under which
any pending proceeding is being had
before any department or agency of the
United States or the due and proper
exercise of the power of inquiry under
which any inquiry or investigation is
being had by either house or any
committee of either house or any Joint
Committee of the Congress it's a
mouthful but what that basically says is
that if if if someone makes
any effort to get in the way of a full
and unfettered investigation or inquiry
by any branch of government that is
obstruction of justice and it appears as
though Donald Trump has obstructed
justice although I don't think that we
need to assume that he's gonna be
charged any time so well probably not
but I mean now we actually have charges
right we have indictments we have guilty
pleas there are actual crimes that he
tried to impede right right the way of
make people not pay his engine that's
interesting which is even though Donald
Trump as of yet has not been even and
certainly not indicted and it's unlikely
that would happen but accused of having
committed any crime this was an
investigation that led to charges which
he tried to impede which gets us to if
Trump had successfully short-circuited
this investigation there would have been
alleged crimes for which indictments
were served that never would have been
if that is not the definition of
obstruction of justice I don't know what
is discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
re d di t today's program is made
possible in part by health IQ hell thank
you too something interesting they use
science and data to secure lower rates
on life insurance for health-conscious
people this includes runners cyclists
strength trainers lots of different ways
that health IQ identifies you as health
conscious 56% of health IQ customers
save between four and thirty three
percent on their life insurance and
those are savings that are exclusive to
health IQ sort of like you can save
money on your car insurance by being a
good driver health IQ gets you lower
rates on life insurance for living a
health-conscious lifestyle because the
the science is there right we have the
numbers physically active people have
lower risks of all-cause mortality lower
risk of heart disease lower risk of
cancer mortality and to see if you
qualify get your free quote at health
iq.com forward slash Pakman that's
health iq.com slash PA k ma n get your
free quote